this is adam rodriguez from finding
magic mike live and i am going to be
here today with the drew barrymore show
revealing some very revealing
superlatives
enjoy i hope they're revealing we'll see
most likely to walk around shirtless
would have to be mcconaughey matthew
mcconaughey
that's a toss-up i mean all of us were
picking if we were standing around there
was a dumbbell in our hand and we were
doing something push-ups curls whatever
it was constantly trying to keep a pump
going so we look good on camera
[Music]
i don't i don't think any of us were
going anywhere in those costumes other
than on stage
that's chan chan is definitely the
dancer of the group so uh he's
definitely gonna be the one improvising
i think we were all hanging on for dear
life
yours truly i'm gonna put myself under
that bus
i have to go with kevin nash kevin had
long hair in the first one i'm gonna go
with kevin on that
you know i don't remember any of the
guys being particularly hairy so i i
don't know that's a toss-up i think
everybody had to do manscaping at a
pretty even pace even though manganello
was a wolf on tv but i don't remember
him being a pretty hairy guy but i don't
know we all got whacks to do these
things so
who knows
[Music]
when we were doing that movie and we got
around each other and we were in a space
but in real life i just not i don't see
it i don't know i don't see that
happening i think um maybe as a group
you could get you know we could we could
get on stage as a group and pull that
off but i don't know if anybody was
going out there in real life you have
the movies you're welcome enjoy those if
you want to see it in real life go to
las vegas berlin london and uh or the
national tour and go see magic mike live
that's not good enough you can catch
finding magic mike on hbo max
i'm gonna say was myself and kevin nash
we formed a brotherhood on set that has
lasted through the years in a very
meaningful way that was my onset and
offset brother as with the rest of the
guys we really did thanks for having me
drew it was a great time great to see
you both you and ross see you next time
[Music]